the rules of welfare don't work don't
save don't get married we'll just keep
you enslaved to this poverty plantation
don't work and I know it firsthand hi
I'm Tracy Oppenheimer for reason TV i'm
here with star Parker founder and
president of cure the center for urban
renewal education why would someone be
against the war on poverty this whole
notion that we should even have a war on
poverty dismisses the fact that
individuals have a role in their own
lives I know firsthand about welfare
welfare dependency because of my own
life live in seven years in and out we
attempted to reform welfare and the 90s
to say at least work should be attached
to this I'm one that really believes the
government has no business in charity
that this is for communities this is for
the private sector to help those who
really cannot help themselves the next
step out of poverty is work so they have
to develop a work ethic well minimum
wage laws aren't helping a very people
that want a war on poverty set up
minimum wage laws keeping people from
being able to work they set up
regulations against business they'd
estate business third step out of
poverty education the very people want
this war on poverty are the ones
standing away or parents have a choice
in education saving and investing fourth
step out of poverty the very people say
let's have a war on poverty or the one
standing way of saving and investing
they're the ones that are hitting us
hard as when we say maybe people should
own their retirement why don't we at
least engage the discussion about money
following you to the entire Minh account
that you own instead of the black hole
of Social Security so if they're not
serious and even in charity the fifth
step out of poverty to give back oh they
stand in a way there too they'd rather
us not be able to tax the duck they
don't like the fact that you have even
religious organizations that say we'll
help specifically with your experience
with dependency on the welfare system
what insight has that given to you that
you think is unique that most other
politicians don't have access to well
I've been there done that these
politicians who have never been anywhere
near an impoverished community and a
person who try to say this is the only
way we're going to do business here are
not even willing to listen you mentioned
the reform in the 90s which I'm sure
you're very familiar with I did face a
lot of resistance there is a big scare
for kids going hungry more people living
in the street
even a full-blown urban crisis in the
words of daniel patrick moynihan one of
the fathers of the war on poverty we're
now 15 years past that it's 2011 could
you say what the differences are between
men and now and do we need more reform
still yes we need more reforms and I was
very much involved in and consulting on
federal welfare reform and I brought my
personal life experiences to the table
to try to assess what do we need to do
as a society to get people to be more
responsible with the choices that
they're making and you're right it was a
very aggressive left that like the
status quo they didn't care how broken
the communities were becoming or the
people that we said that we were trying
to help in fact I received several death
threats at that time just because I was
consulted on the federal welfare bill
but post welfare what we saw based on
what we knew ninety-eight percent were
just single women trying to raise
children and we knew that ninety percent
of them had high school diplomas that
they had some work experience that they
knew what to do to transition their
lives and yet needed a nudge to do such
right after welfare reform was passed we
saw those women leave and go to work the
roles dropped in half we didn't see
babies starving when you see people
dying in the streets do we still need
more reform on a local level absolutely
while numbers are going up because
unemployment has gone up so many are
going to government to look for food
stamps and or some type of subsidy the
system itself has to be totally
overhauled and changed could you maybe
rate Obama's administration in regards
to welfare and maybe given the grade his
grade is f I'm keep in mind that in the
60s when they started the social
engineering black family life was
relatively intact 22% out of wedlock
birth rates today seventy-two percent
they collapsed the family what Barack
Obama is attempting to do is spread that
out into her great middle class and are
in our suburban communities these are
the same ideas but we've already tried
them and you can look into any and every
one of those four thousand housing
projects that are still left standing
and say this is not what we should be
doing for the rest of the country this
is the wrong direction do you think that
the current system marginalizes
minorities when you think about the
silver
movement it was a movement to remove
governmental barriers Jim Crow was a
governmental barrier remove these
barriers so that we can educate so that
we can attain economic success rather
than us continue on that journey to say
okay we've removed these barriers now go
live free many that took up the mantle
after dr. King's death went to
Washington and politicized the movement
and so you started seeing the interest
of the community move toward government
intervention when you think about
government intervention not only did the
welfare class start to unravel that
entire community the working class
started to become addicted to government
today the government is the number one
employer of black men and the second
large it's employer black women this
should not occur in a free society what
about the people who started at rock
bottom whether it be a mental or
physical handicap or just those who grew
up in absolute worst situation two
things number one you've got to be able
to identify who they are amongst us that
absolutely cannot help themselves they
have no one they have no resources
that's actually one reason we should not
have the government in this business
they can't identify this has only done
on a very local in personal level number
two once we've identified them how do we
help how do we really help those that
cannot help themselves well you empower
their charities local charities and
empowerment how do you do that does the
government redistribute 700 billion or
do you allow free people to freely give
to the charity they most want to this is
why I'm for charity tax credits number
three though what has to happen on the
second part of your question and those
that can't help themselves and or
they're just at risk because of the
environment that they lived in their
parents are total losers and now they're
stuck that's why it's so important to
have school choice we must allow for
money to follow children to the school
that their parent and/or the community
will best be able to serve them through
I know you do talk a lot about or put a
lot of emphasis on faith can you pull
yourself out of poverty without religion
people can pull themselves out of
poverty without religion but that said
when you're talking about those most at
risk they have to know why they believe
what they do without a moral
compass which some do take for granted
we can call it religion or we can just
call it a moral compass short of that
you cannot then define right from wrong
so what we want to do is make sure that
they have a moral framework built inside
of them as they mature to become adults
this is where religious instruction can
serve them best you know you've had a
very multifaceted career could you tell
us a little bit about what you've done
so far and what you plan to do in the
near future through my organization cure
we built out a pastor program so that we
can inform them about what is broken
down in their community so that they can
focus more on fixing it working then to
get them to open schools once again
professionally I would like to see a
whole lot of legislative changes I think
just economically if we were to do
something as simple as personal
retirement accounts in Social Security
we could break cycle of poverty in one
generation